hi there this is Steve Kaufman here
again founder of Lync and of course I
have a blog the linguist on language and
recently we've had a lot of interest
after blog one of the items of interest
was my discussion with many the Irish
polyglot the polyglot and I think we
should probably have another round this
time we'll take the gloves off should be
fun
and I think we shouldn't misunderstand I
really like Benny's enthusiasm I think
he gets a little too enthusiastic at
times in and I do feel is a little
dismissive of other approaches I don't
dispute that he does what he claims to
do I just don't think it is as his
methods are as universally applicable as
he claims but anyway we'll talk about
that and get on that and have a
discussion on before I get going what
I'm going to talk about today by the way
is this business about don't be
judgmental and how there is a whole
climate of discouraging open and fresh
discussion which seems to be coming out
of our school systems and in our
universities and so forth but before I
get there I just people have asked me
about the books behind me so this is a
small part of my library and what you
have over on this side here are books on
history largely at the very top up there
are my books Japanese books over on this
side here is mostly my Chinese books
books related to Chinese but I wanted to
fill up the books because they were kind
of flopping over so I put some teach
yourself books up there that somebody
noticed because I have bought quite a
few of you know language learning books
on different for different languages
just to learn what people are doing and
and also to start on languages in the
past Korean
beginning with Russian and so forth and
so on I have sections in Spanish and
Portuguese and Russian and English
Canadian history world history I got a
whole section on evolution which is an
area of interest I can't remember what
they all are lots of history books so
there you have it if one day I might
keep our interested we can exchange
information on the books we like don't
be judgemental some I hear this all the
time don't be judgemental why not be
judgmental we have to judge we're
judging all the time did you like the
movie did you like dinner do you like
that person we are always judgmental why
shouldn't we frankly state how we feel
and on my blog you know I had various
responses to this someone said well it's
not don't be judgmental it's don't be so
judgmental
you shouldn't be so judgmental well what
does that mean
how either you make judgments you have
opinions or you don't you don't very
much have opinions you're allowed to
have opinions some people have more and
I think the more opinions would have on
things the better it means that you're
observing and thinking or trying to
think for yourself now granted we're
always influenced in every opinion that
we hold it's because of something that
someone said to us or that we read which
is fine but I like to maintain this this
feeling that I'm in control of my
opinions you know during Nazi Germany
people were not judgmental and so
therefore they allowed the Germans
allowed these Nazi thugs to take over
their country with the consequences that
we know the the I think even more
important than democracy is freedom you
can have governments that are like Hong
Kong for example was not a democracy but
they had freedom they could express
their opinions and I think it's very
important that we maintain this freedom
to express our opinions the greatest
protection
against Nazism fascism communism any
kind of ISM that wants to control our
lives and take away a lot of our basic
freedoms is the freedom of expression
but now in schools we are taught not to
present our views and I think again
someone on my blog said well don't state
your opinion why don't you just ask the
other person what they think well
they'll tell me what they think and I
often do ask and we do ask guys we're
having a discussion and pump somebody
says something that I don't agree with
well I'll say well I don't agree why do
you say that so we do ask questions and
very often on my blog if I lead with a
question saying what do you think of
this and then someone will volunteer an
opinion and I'll say no I don't agree
then I'll very often get well why did
you ask the question if you don't you
know if you're gonna argue with me or
something like as if if someone puts
forward an opinion I'm obliged to agree
with it I'm not obliged to agree and I
had one person on the blog post that I
had on don't be judgmental and this
fellow's a teacher because I clicked
through his his name and he was bound
and determined to come to a harmonious
agreement and he kept trying different
things and then he would say there are
we harmonious now well no we're not
because you have one opinion which is
fine
perfectly legitimate for you how to have
an opinion you're not obliged to agree
with me I'm not obliged to agree with
you the purpose of our discussion is not
to arrive at an agreement this is not a
peace negotiation we're discussing
something and hearing your views
undoubtedly is good for me gets my brain
cells going I have to try to find
arguments to defend my position I look
at your arguments to see there what
there is a value and you may influence
me mostly we don't influence people in
the discussion at least not immediately
not during the heat of the discussion
but it may meet at the following day we
say you know what yeah we say to
ourselves that hey maybe had a point so
I think these free discussions are very
beneficial very fruitful I
this teachers listserv that I've often
referred to where they kept on censoring
my comments because they thought I was
being too forceful at times and I would
say you know I don't agree like I said
you know we should look at the other
side of the coin or something no you
can't say that or I think we were
discussing the Japanese during the war
and I said there were some hot-headed
you know middle level officers who
precipitated that the war in China and
that was censored because if I said the
Japanese officers were hot-headed that
might offend some Japanese Americans
that's what they thought which is
completely ridiculous and at any rate so
I was arguing with this sensor and I
said why do yu censor these things and
we went back and forth and then finally
she sort of gave her final argument and
then there do you get it now she said
like I'm obliged to get it I don't have
to get it we can both go in parallel
directions you have your opinion but you
can stay as often as you want and I have
mine
and I think this is extremely healthy
and basically when when and I was at
this a thing here at Simon Fraser
University here in Vancouver called the
school of dialogue which is the biggest
windbag exercise I've ever come across
they totally discourage people from
expressing their opinions and they
organized a one-day conference on what
does it mean to be Canadian which is
full of things that are not relevant to
most Canadians relevant the most
Canadians is the hockey game were
counting to beat the United States or
beat Russia that's significant but they
were talking about was not very
significant but the teachers group they
had invited a bunch of people you know
be around town to come businesspeople
whatever to sit in on this discussion
and it began by lecturing us on
dialoguing that it's very important that
we understand that we shouldn't be too
forceful and or trying to persuade
people of our views we should be
dialoguing and then 20-minute lecture
and how to talk I happen to sit at a
table with him and I told him what my
views were
on multiculturalism that I'm not in
favor of it I think that's a private
thing you can be as multicultural as you
want individually but I don't think that
the state should be promoting it I think
that's a bad thing to do I mean all I
said was that mild more mildly because
we were you know we have more time to
talk about well he practically grabbed
me by the throat this is this dialoguing
guy the minute I said something that
didn't fit in with his you know whatever
he's been taught at school where
everybody thinks the same I mean he went
berserk he called me a racist bigot and
all this kind of stuff so that's
dialoguing I think teachers should make
a lot of sources of information
available the students encourage them to
read encourage them to think don't teach
them how to think don't teach them
critical thinking don't teach them
dialoguing don't teach them how to be
nice and expressing their views let them
think for themselves
let them be judgmental let us all as
human beings exercise our right and our
ability as as moral beings to judge
what's happening and to state how we
feel about things and that's got nothing
to do with racism or anything else it
has to do with thinking for yourself and
speaking for yourself